So what did we do the last time?
Yeah,
that's what we were talking about.
We are trying to describe
an event as seen by two observers.
One will be called s and here's the x axis [inaudible] that is call s prime is
frame is sliding to the right at velocity.
You
therefore are at a certain time.
Let me say s is me and this Brian Miss you.
When you pass me,
I'm sitting at the audit and the my coordinates x equal to zero.
You are at the origin of your moving coordinates.
Explained equals zero and when we crossed each other that time we said a zero in
know would own clocks.
We synchronize them
so that the event x equals zero x prime equals t equal to zero also had caught
in it explained me equals zero d prime equals zero when you and I crossed,
we pushed our stopwatches,
we synchronized our clocks about origins go coincided and that's when it began.
So after some time you are here.
This is your frame and this is my frame.
If something happens here,
something could be anything.
Event is,
I hope you understand what an event is.
That's not a relativist Ignatian.
That's the very old notion.
Something happens to someplace five track.
It goes off.
I asked you when did it happen and where did it happen and you will given the
coordinates.
Everything that happens is an event.
You saw Elvis.
I say,
where did you see Elvis?
At the supermarket.
Okay,
when did you see Elvis?
I would also ask you what you were smoking because this third question,
that's not a third.
That's not an extra coordinate,
but in this case I would have left.
Well,
I should tell you beyond all the laughter,
that's the cts issue.
Why is that not a coordinate?
Why not ask more and more questions and call them all coordinates.
The reason the other things are not coordinates is very important.
Why is time now suddenly a coordinate?
Whereas you could have always asked a hundred years ago when there's something
happen and the reason is that you will see in the new relativistic physics x and
t according to one person get mixed up into x,
Raymond v Prime of the other person.
The fact that space and time coordinates can be combined to give the new space
and time coordinates is why it's called a coordinator.
I'll say more about it later.
No.
By the way,
I posted some notes on this topic.
For those of you who want to have a second pass at it,
I also don't know how much the textbook covers this topic because I spend a lot
of time on this topic,
not in proportion to what's in the book,
so you can look at those notes which I posted today before all the Einstein
stuff.
If something occurred here,
you would say it's at a distance.
Explain from your origin.
I will say it's at a distance extra.
My origin,
this difference between our audience would be ut.
Therefore before Einstein,
I would say x prime is x minus ut
and you would say
x should be what you think is a coordinate plus Uti.
Yeah.
This is just going back and forth from you to me and you can already notice that
to go back and forth from you.
To me.
We just change the sign of the velocity cause I'm going to the right.
Then you are going to the left.
That's why the formulas of sign of university,
what is the big change after that Enstein first is I admit the possibility that
maybe you will think the time elapsed since we synchronize our clocks is not
necessarily the same.
I leave that option.
Oakland,
the t and t prime are not the same.
Second thing I do is I already explained to you that the velocity of light
coming out the same for different people.
It's very counterintuitive because if you're going to the right,
I expect you to get a smaller speed and you to get the same answer so we know
that it's because we don't agree anymore on clocks and meters,
six being the same,
so in particular you will say,
I don't buy your prediction that I expect to get the answer to be x minus ut.
I'm going to put a fudge factor.
Gamma with depends on the velocity between you and me because your lengths are
not my legs and likewise,
I will tell you I don't agree with your expectation that I should get
explainable as ut prime.
I don't believe your lengths are really my lengths,
but I'm going to put the same fudge factor,
Gamma
disability,
interesting result.
If I think your meter sticks are short so that I want to blow up the answer with
some amount.
You're allowed to say the same about me because one of the big paradox is and
real activity that we can accuse each other of using meter sticks which are
short,
and we'll go into a little bit about how that's even possible,
but the postulates tell us that if my efforts fact that is gamma,
your should also be the same gamma.
So gamma is what we don't know.
I showed you a trick to find gamma.
I said,
let's imagine that this event here,
which could have been a firecracker,
is triggered by a light pulse.
That resentment when you and I met here,
the light poles goes racing and sets off an explosion here.
That's the event we're talking about.
That's not a generic event.
It's a particular event in which x has to be c Times d because that's the for
the light poles.
According to me,
light goes to the velocity of c and the event has got the same velocity
according to you.
This event here
should be connected by light poles.
That foot x over t is c and x prime over t prime is the same seat.
Then I said dig this street questions multiply the lefthand side,
but the left hand side,
right hand,
the right hand side put in these numbers and extract gamma.
And I will not repeat that part.
And gamma was this.
Yeah.
Once you've got this,
you can take this gamma and pull it back here.
Let's see what we get cause I'm going to put what we get here into this board.
Uh,
you guys got all of that.
Okay,
so I'm going to put it back here because this is just bagged on from last
lecture.
What we have then is x prime is x minus ut,
delighted by this
famous square root.
And if you go and solve for t prime in the other equation,
it's a simple algebraic manipulations.
I don't want to waste my time doing that.
You will find tip frame is equal to t minus UX overseas square divided by the
same squared root.
Yeah,
these are priceless.
This is really all I've relatively,
all the funny stuff you hear about equals mc squared,
funny clogs,
the twin paradox.
Everything comes from these equations
and you people should be very pleased that within what,
six weeks of starting physics 200 you have all the things you need to understand
these equations to understand where they came from.
That's also the remarkable thing about relativity.
Lot of the modern things in physics required a lot of mathematics.
In fact,
if you want to take a beam and you want to load it with weight and you want to
see the stresses and strains the map in while that is thousand times more
difficult than this one,
and yet the mathematics of relativity is very,
very simple and accessible to all of you.
And that is nothing that I know that you don't know as far as how to get these
equations.
This is what you do.
Everything follows from taking these equations and analyzing them,
extracting the consequences.
And that's really more an issue of coverage than just intelligence.
Because once you've got these equations,
you will have to take them wherever they,
you'll have to follow them where they take you.
And that's what we're going to do.
The rest of the whole remaining lectures are all about getting information from
this equation.
Now,
some of you are not used to writing equations.
I have noticed,
uh,
when you see something like this,
it's not clear what is being stated.
Let me to my new one more time.
You as a fixed number that's spirit elective to mind.
I see something happening.
I give it a pat of numbers x t you give the same event,
another pair of numbers explain p prime and this is how they relate.
So I gave you an analogy but let me repeat the analogy you feel now talking with
the x y plane rather than the XD plane.
That dart is not an event.
that.is a coordinate of a point.
Maybe where something is city I give to it.
Pair of numbers x and y
no you have a different coordinate system rotated relative to mine by some angle
data.
But that same court,
same location,
you measure x prime up to here and t prime from there a lot.
I'm sorry.
X Prime and wipe frame automation along your access.
Okay.
And the formula there is x Prime Xcor sine theta,
uh,
less white signed data
and wipe prime minus x sine data.
This white core science data
data is the analog of the velocity.
Then you take the zero.
You and I agree completely.
Ted is not zero.
Your access is it rotated relative to mine.
And the same point has two different numbers.
X,
Y for me.
Explain why pipe for you and the relation between them is this.
So you plug in my x and y you can get your experiment wipe right.
Let me give a concrete example.
Let's take that Eiko to fire over four or 45 degrees.
Then as you know,
at 45 sine and cosine,
and they're all the same one over route too.
So in that case,
x prime is x over two to less.
Why overruled two and white frame is minus x over route two plus y over route
two.
That's a special case when theater is 45 degrees.
So for every angle costs in st Mildred used to usual simple numbers happen to be
a square root of two here.
Then it tells you my x and y are related to your experiment way prime in this
manner.
And you can test it.
For example,
take a product,
uh,
take a point with coordinates one,
one
x.
Why is one one,
if x,
y is one one and my access is it related to yours before,
if I degree one,
one lies right there.
So what I expect is your wife Prime.
There is no white frame and the quart in there should be entirely expert.
If I put in one one and you find if I put x equals y equal,
the one wipe prime becomes zero.
And how about x prime?
It becomes one plus one over route to that means,
uh,
route two over route to just square root of two.
And a squad would have to of course would be the lengthy measured this way
because the length of the vector is square root of two and the vectors entirely
along the x direction.
So the length you will get for this coordinator will be rude to so come back to
these equations.
They are the same thing.
If you want,
I can write an x prime s x divided by this number minus you divided by this
number Times d.
So you can think of one over this number here as the analog of cost data and you
over this number as the analog of side.
So it just that,
uh,
instead of costume saying all being upstairs,
some of the numbers are down,
some of the numbers set up.
But for a given you,
these are all some numbers constant depending on you and x prime.
It's a linear combination of x and t and t prime is some of the linear
combination of accent,
but I should warn you that it is not an ordinary rotation.
In other words,
you cannot treat this as a co signer that as a sign,
they're not school centered sign of anything because if they were this square
was that square should add up to one and they won't.
So don't even try that.
This is not an ordinary day rotation,
but it is still what you can call a linear transformation.
Your transformation means the new numbers are related to the first power.
So the old numbers,
they are linear.
They don't involve t squared and x squared,
okay,
so that is the content of the load.
In San summation,
everybody should understand what they do.
Better way of going back and forth.
Now you can go backwards.
You can say,
well,
how do I write x in terms of x prime and t prime?
There are two options open to you.
One is a decent simultaneous equations.
You got to find a way to solve for x and T in terms of experiment d prime and
all these funny functions involving you treat them all as constants and juggle
them around,
multiply by this divided by that what you shouldn't do that because you know
what the answer should be.
The answer should be the same as what I got with the velocity reversed.
So x will be x prime plus you tip frame or the square root.
If I write the way too,
it means I don't feel like putting what's in it at the same old thing.
So they got tired of writing.
That deep prime will be t plus Ux overseas squares divided by square root.
So once you'd be able to go back and forth,
just like in this formula if you like,
I gave it to you as example,
long back as a homework problem,
you can write a new formula that says x is equal to x prime cost sine theta
minus y signed data and y prime is equal to something.
I mean why you circled something,
something and the way to get that as either solve the equations.
I realized that if I go from me to you by a data,
I go from you to me by minus state and all you have to do is change,
signed,
dated,
minus sainted and leave the coastline there alone.
Similarly here you change the sign of the velocity.
You to get the river's transformations.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that does the Lorentz transformation.
Not we're going to start milking the tram,
salvation,
everything is going to be applying it to understand various things.
The first step in getting the mileage out of the Lord.
In Sam's summation,
you stick a pair of events.
I urge you whenever you get a problem in relativity to think in terms of events
and quite often think in terms of pair up events to events.
So event one is uh,
let me give concrete events and most of the leftovers,
the examples involve some degree of violence.
And so this one in walls had gun.
So I would take this gun.
So I'm not going to point in any of you guys.
I fired the gun.
That's event one.
Then gun a bullet hits a wall.
That's even too,
you can take to events connected by a bullet leaving me and hitting the wall,
or you can take to events not connected to anything.
Okay.
We can take two unrelated events but doesn't matter.
We go,
we're going to call them event one event two,
so even one we'll have coordinates x one t one right and according to you,
excellent prime t one pri.
So right,
the load and transformation that first relates x one prime is x one Wayne is
[inaudible] t one over the square root.
Then right here,
p one prime is t one minus u x one four c squared divided by the square root.
Similarly,
take the second event and write the law for that matter.
It's the same thing with the new numbers in it,
sort of p to prime the teeth two minus u x to overseas square divided by square
root.
Now take the difference of two minus one.
You can take one minus two but it's very common to define.
The difference would be two minus one and call it Delta x two prime delta x two
prime is identical to the delta x prime is extra prime minus x one prime.
All the deltas will be defined to be second minus the first.
I'm telling you to take x one frame subtracted from x two prime on the left hand
side and call it Delta of exploring Deltav explain is the difference in the
spatial coordinate to the two events according to you,
if you come to the right hand side,
now this is something you guys should be able to do in your head.
I want to subtract that from that.
They shared the same denominator so that,
let me put the denominator there.
Yes.
In the numerator you you'll get x two minus x one which in my convention I would
call it Delta x and the other one will be you delta t.
What this tells you is that differences in coordinates also obey the same load
and transformation.
Instead of seeing the coordinator.
If an event was XD and you could explain t prime from the Lord and Sam
summation.
If you take a pair of events and they are separated in space by Delta x and in
time by Delta t according to me,
the separation according to you,
your delta x primes and Delta t frames are given by similar formulas as the
Deloitte and stamps summation for the delta of the way.
This just came from taking the difference of three questions applied to the two
separate events.
All right.
You can also do this backwards if you like.
If you want the differences that I get in terms of yours and yours in terms of
mine,
you have to reverse the sign of you so I won't do that again.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Here.
Yeah.
Uh,
this was the formula for x in terms of x prime and deep pride and t prime in
terms of t and X.
Oh,
here.
You don't want that
primes on the bottom.
Okay.
I got to give some numbers.
This is a,
this is B.
This is c.
What is the problem?
One of you,
the right of seat.
Oh,
oh,
yes,
of course.
Yes.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now public apologies forthcoming.
You want me to do this?
Yes.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Do not hesitate to do this.
In fact,
when I said,
uh,
I don't know any more than you do about this,
it looks like I know less than you do about it.
So the fact that I know this doesn't mean I'm going to get it right.
So all of you screwed up in the midterm member.
That is hope for you.
Maybe you want to do ELA students,
but you can become a professor here.
Okay?
It's all right for us to get things wrong.
That's correct.
Very good.
Okay,
so if you're following me that well,
I'm very happy and out and all.
You must be following what I'm saying here.
So now let us
everything.
No,
I keep telling you I'm building it up in a big way,
but everything really is going to come from this version of the Lord and his
transformation for differences.
Look,
suppose you are smart enough like Einstein and he did use these equations for
gamma.
What do you do next?
You know,
you write them down.
You can publish them and say,
according to me,
this is the rule for transformation,
but you cannot stop.
No.
You have to say,
what are the implications of my equations?
Because these equations are dramatic variations of Newtonian laws.
For example,
let's just do one thing to events are separated but 10 meters according to me,
they'll tax prime.
You've dealt acts as 10 meters at Delta X.
Prime is not 10 meters is 10 minus something divided by something,
so that distance between two events is changing.
That's not supposed to happen just because you get into a train,
right?
If I hold my hands and said I caught a fish that big,
that distance should be same for me and the trainer.
If you look at me bragging in the train from outside the train,
you should find the same distance.
We're saying it's not true.
Likewise,
if I say to events took place and I came to Yale on a certain day,
I got a degree four years later,
that's supposed to be true for anybody,
but that's also not true.
If Delta t is for years does x is whatever you like.
Maybe you never left new haven,
so delta x zero that's four years,
that's not four years.
These are all drastic
consequences and being going to explore the consequences.
The first thing I'm going to do is to make sure that the velocity
transformations from one frame to another,
obey the requirements we set on it.
So he had what I'm going to do event one,
I fired the gun.
Okay,
let me just call it event one.
I fired the gun even to a bullet hits the wall.
So the separation between these two events is the delta x for me and the time it
took.
The bullet is Delta t.
You can also see the bullet from your train and you think the distance between
me and the wall or something at the time between the fighting and hitting a wall
or something else than what would developed.
What's the velocity of the bullet?
According to you and me?
V
It's velocity of bullets
for me
would be Delta x
over Delta T.
Okay.
No,
I should be a little more careful with my rotation.
Usually Delta said use for infor decimal numbers,
especially when you're going to define the velocity.
Velocity is the limit of these guys going to zero?
What's the property of learning Samsung [inaudible] that at this level,
when I say differences in time,
differences in space,
they had not necessarily small.
Nowhere was a assuming that the difference in x was smaller.
Difference in needs more.
They could be even separated by five light years.
You can still use them.
So at this stage,
don't think delta x has to be infinite decimal.
It is simply a shorthand for difference.
If I had that all the time in the world,
I would write everything is x two minus x one but I'm using delta as a short
hand,
but when I'm going to find the velocity of a bullet,
which could even be the instantaneous velocity,
then he had,
I do want to take the limit in which they go to zero.
Third becomes ds Dxdt.
So from now on,
for this purpose off velocity calculation,
you should take them to be infinitesimal decimal and approaching zero but not in
general.
These equations are valid for Orbitz or big introvert us in time and space.
Now W let,
it'd be the velocity for you.
That is ims and urs prime.
W is delta x prime or Delta t prime with suitable limits.
Yeah.
Well from this transformation lost,
you can get the,
because here is delta x frame and hit his Delta p prime led me divide this
by this on the lefthand side to get w
when I write delta x prime over Delta t prime,
you guys take the limits of everything going to zero.
I don't feel like writing that isn't,
in fact it's true even without the limit,
but let's apply it in the end to instantaneous velocity.
Then what happens in the right hand side here is what delta x prime is equal to
you.
Can you do this in your head?
If this delta x minus you Delta t denominated cancels between dividing this by
this it looks like,
okay,
yeah,
I just divided this guy by this guy because that's we need to divide the
lefthand side,
but the left hand side you have to do by the right hand side,
by the right hand side.
Now you should have an idea of what I'm planning to do.
What do we do next?
Do this expression here?
Yes.
A limit of what if it just take the limit of Delta t going to zero.
You just going to get zero.
That's the limit you want to take.
You got to bring the philosophies into the picture.
Yes.
Pardon me.
No for any value of you.
Yes.
What you want to do now is to divide the top and bottom of this by Delta t
because you got the velocity of the bullet.
Uh,
according to you,
I want to get the velocity,
the bullet according to me into the picture.
That is Delta x over Delta T.
Well,
this is not a typical derivative in calculus.
Okay?
You got to divide everything by Delta t,
then you will get delta x over Delta t there minus you divided by one minus.
You will see square time,
Delta x over Delta t.
This is true even for finite differences.
Now take the limit.
Then this becomes the last year of the bullet minus you there by one minus you
be overseas square.
So you got to drop box it on this guy.
This is another great formula.
So I hope you know why I divided by Delta t I wanted to find the velocity,
the bullet according to you and according to me for you.
I took the distance over time.
Well,
I've got all these distances and times and the top and bottom side divided by
the time.
So everything turns into a velocity.
So this is the velocity of the bullet according to me.
If they're going to the right at a speed,
you in the good old days,
what did they expect?
You've got to understand that they,
my expectation the old days would be the minus you,
right?
Well let's going at speed.
V You're going at speed you to the right.
So you will see a diminished speed by an amount equal your speed,
but now it's the twist or something in the bottom.
The stuff in the bottom is a number less than one because one minus something,
they're going to jack up velocity.
Therefore,
the velocity you will actually measure somewhat bigger than what I expected in
the old days.
If you ever want to get back to the good old days in any the calculation,
you should let the velocity of light gold,
infinity.
Of course it's not infinity.
What you really mean is you oversee and v oversee are negligible.
That means my velocity,
the bullet velocity,
they're all small competitive velocity of light.
If we get back the answer from the whole base,
this the answer from the new days,
no,
let's find the beauty of this result.
Let's get the diverse result.
Let us solve for the velocity I get in terms of velocity you get,
again,
I think you realize you can do the Algebra,
but you guys should know that to go from me back to you,
I should simply reverse the sign of of a relative velocity.
Okay?
Yeah.
This
is the backwards was up.
Now the way you are in a train and you fired a bullet towards the front of the
train,
what speed do I attribute to the bullet from the ground?
Well,
I had the bullet speed to the train speed.
That's what the numerator is.
The nominated says the answer is somewhat less than that by this number.
Yes.
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
Yeah,
I mean what?
That's absolutely correct.
What I really need to do.
It's quite correct.
It's not simply the change you to minus you what the chain,
the velocities that you were seeing and put them in the place of velocities that
I was seeing.
That's correct.
This is what you want to get.
Now let's look at the strength of this result.
If someone tells you according to relativity,
nothing can go faster than the speed of light.
You can try to beat the system as follows.
You can come to me and say,
can there be a gun?
Who's bullets go at three fourth the velocity of light and I would say yes,
and you went to how board?
A train that goes at three for the velocity of light and out to that seems to be
allowed.
Then you can say,
well,
let me get into the strain at day four,
the velocity of light and fire a bullet at three 40 velocity.
Then from the ground,
it should appear to be going at 1.5 times over the last year of life.
Well,
that's the naive expectation,
but if you do it now,
let's put w equals three four C and you equally three four see the all answer
this disaster.
It says 1.5 c but the correct answer is that plus three four square.
So what is this guy?
Uh,
this is
1.5 c divided by one plus nine over 16
that's a good one to play everything by 16 on the top you'd get 24 the bottom,
you'll get 25 see,
you see,
you can
jack up the velocity as seen by the ground,
but it'll never be 1.5 it'll still be less than the velocity of light.
Yeah.
And the last thing you want to check out,
this velocity addition formula is wipe you started the whole thing.
In other words,
suppose you suppose I see a pulse of light.
Let's go back now.
This formula w is the minus you over one minus UV overseas square.
Rather than applying it to a bullet or whatnot.
Let's apply to the light pulse itself.
So I saw light posts.
So I say the object I saw,
which is what lead stands for,
had the value c and this is the pretty Einstein expectation.
W should be c minus you because the pulse will appear to travel slower to person
will being in the same direction as the pulse.
But our new formula says it is really that times u times see overseas squared.
Yeah.
So that canceled one part of c,
multiply the top and bottom by sea and you will find it a c.
So the last year late will always come out to be the same.
That was built into the formulas,
but it's a good thing to test.
Yeah.
So what you find is Bella,
it don't add in a simple way.
If they did,
you are in trouble.
You cannot get an upper limit if they added in the simple way because you can
put a rocket in spade,
another rocket inside and on the rocket and add up all the speeds.
And even though each one is less than,
see the Jordan could be whatever you like,
but they don't add that way.
They add this way so that the answer this either bigger than what you think.
If we end you are opposite,
are smarter than what you think.
If the velocities in the top out of the same size,
no matter what you do,
the answer will always be less than C.
Okay?
So that just the first conclusion from this
second conclusion.
Second conclusion,
which is again very staggering,
is that simultaneity is a relative concept.
In other words,
if two events,
I could at the same time for me,
they don't get at the same time for you,
that's very surprising.
But example,
if you have twins,
barn,
one in new Saudi prince cannot be born in New York and Los Angeles.
So I got two kids of different,
uh,
motherhood just happened to be born at the same time.
And I say at time,
we're not talking about trivial three hour time difference between Los Angeles,
New York.
That's an artificial thing.
In the Einstein world,
you imagine we all have clocks that read the same time.
So by that measure,
the kid two kids are born at the same time.
But if you watch that from a moving train and moving rocket,
you will disagree on that.
You will in fact say Vietnam simultaneous.
How does that come?
Where does come from going to this formula?
Delta t prime is Delta t minus you delta x overseas square divided by this
number.
And all I'm telling you is even though Delta t zero t prime is not zero
either,
shock simultaneity is not absolute.
We think we used to think it's absolutely,
in other words,
do events.
I could hang in Los Angeles and New York,
there can be arranged to be simultaneous for me living on the planet,
let's say.
But if you go in a rocket,
I expect you to agree they were simultaneous.
I mean how can it be different to things that are happening right now at
different places?
It's got to be right now for you,
but it's not.
It just comes from that formula.
Once again,
if the velocity of light is made much bigger than everything in the problem,
simply to set it to infinity,
you will find out that the prime,
a Delta t that goes back to Galilee and time,
so the old pre Einstein Times.
That's why in relativity space and time form a new space,
time and time is called the fourth component because if c goes to infinity,
Delta Primus always dealt at t and t prime is always do that.
Coordinate never mixes with anything else,
doesn't deserve to be called a coordinate betters.
The X and y coordinates,
they mixed into each other.
When you do rotations in after the Einstein,
the space and time coordinates mixed with each other to give you a new space and
time coordinates under Lorentz transformations,
which means when seen in a moving frame
that's white time is no elevated to another dimension because it transforms very
much the way.
Excellent.
Why did the details of the transformation are different.
You have science of course and replaced by you and you over the square root,
but it's still mathematically the way components of factors will transform.
Okay,
so simultaneity is relative.
So you have to ask yourself,
how did that happen?
So here is the famous example that was given in all the books.
Maybe it was given by Einstein,
I'm not sure.
So he hit us a train.
Let's say the train is at rest and you're standing in the middle and you want to
arrange for two events to be simultaneous.
Oh by the way,
that is one cat.
You have the two events occurred at the same time and the same place.
Bell tax is zero,
Delta t is zero.
Then the transformation will tell you Dell Pax prime is zero and Delta p prime
is zero
because two events occurring at the same time at the same place means for
example,
my two hands came and [inaudible] the two hands,
but at the same time at the same place.
If someone said,
well Dave or not at the same place at the same time,
it means I did not play our two cars collide.
So if two things occurred at the same time,
at the same place,
something happened that the mapped in space time,
you cannot find another observer who says they did not meet in spacetime I,
they'll say the two cars did not collide.
Soda activity even after relativity,
the strewed that two events at the same time and same place occurred at the same
time and same place for all people.
Same time alone is not enough in the same place alone is not enough.
You see that if two cars came
and they collided,
they were at the same time,
at the same place,
the cards,
but at the same time here and there,
that's no accident if they,
but at the same place,
because this car went and two minutes later that Carter went to the same place,
nothing happens,
right?
That's what you say,
this board guy,
he was in the wrong place at the wrong time.
You don't have to say this guy was at the wrong place.
What does that mean?
You can go to the battle of Gettysburg site and stand.
No,
nothing happens to you because at the same place,
but it's the wrong time.
Okay?
We all realized simply same time,
it's a congruence in space time.
And even after Einstein,
you cannot say something did not happen.
Good.
We're gonna leave that the politician,
these didn't happen.
This didn't happen.
And the equations have the property,
but I'm considering events separated in space,
but at the same time,
so you got on the train.
You're job is to make two things happen at the same time.
And here's what you do.
You send a beam of light,
the splits into,
uh,
you know,
he has a blown,
I picked a beam of light comes and splits like that and goes to the back in
front of the train.
You are in the middle of the train and you know that events will be simultaneous
for you.
The pulse travels on either side and hits the two things.
The two end sets off to explosions and you have done the best you can have
simultaneous events.
Okay?
Okay.
Now I see you from the ground.
All this happening and the moving train,
you have every right to say you're not moving,
but to me relative to me are moving.
That's the fact.
And I look at how well you did with this.
Okay,
so you sent out this to light pulses.
Then what happened?
This wall of the train is moving away from the light post.
This wallet,
the train,
the rear end is rushing to meet the light bulbs.
Oh,
the velocity of light is the same for everybody.
So yeah,
I can think in terms of what happens if one wall is rushing to meet the light
poles in one wall is running away from the light poles.
I know very clearly the firecracker in the back of the train will go off first
end of the front of the train would go off later.
That means that don't that the will not be zero.
In fact,
you can see Delta t will be negative because the event with the greater,
the x coordinate occurs later.
Yeah,
and that's also an ugly men to the formula of Delta t zero Deltek's Brian will
be some negative numbers.
No.
Why did we bring in the light poles?
We bring in the light poles because we can tell that they would simply will not
be simultaneous because about the light.
We know this.
It's velocity is same for everybody.
That's the way all arguments in relativity involved doing things with light
pulses are communicating with the light posts because we know what light does.
It travels at one in the same velocity for all people at the postulate.
Therefore we know you couldn't have done any better in making them simultaneous
and I simply disagree with you.
I'd say they just did not happen at the same time and there's no question of who
is right operationally for me,
those two events were separated in time by some are more and for you they were
not.
That's a great new idea that things did not happen at the same time for all
people and really sturdy tells you that they didn't and tells you about how much
they will differ.
Okay.
Then I take the next sort of price here.
Next surprise has to do with clocks.
The claim is that clocks will not run at the same rate.
Okay.
When we bought the clocks,
we compared them,
we got them from the same shop,
they would completely in sync and you put one in your train and you got into
your train and the claim is that I will find that your clocks are running slow.
Let me show that to you again.
You can want to do anything.
Relativity at least learned this one thing.
Go back to the Lord and Sam summation and think in terms of events than it just
going to come out of the wash.
If you try something original on your own,
you people do all kinds of stuff.
I've seen you going into cyclical,
circular arguments from which you cannot even come out to somebody rescues you.
So don't do that.
So I'm looking at a clock.
You've got to ask yourself,
how do I turn this issue of time into a pair of events?
I have my clock.
So it goes tick tock,
tick tock.
I take to events.
Even the one clock says stick
and even to clock says stock.
I tell you why I have taken talk because I wanted to have two distinct kind of
events.
We can talk about them.
So this event is a clock that I am carrying with me.
Clock is with me.
So let me put the clock at the center of my coordinate system or the origin.
It doesn't matter where it is.
Let me put it on the origin.
The space time coordinate is x equals zero t equals zero is the first tick of
the clock.
How about the next tick,
the next stick.
This is x and t coordinates the talk of the clock.
Let me call [inaudible] is the time of the clock,
the time period.
How many seconds elapsed between the tick and the Tock?
Main question is what is the location of the second take out the talk.
Where does that happen?
Yes,
it doesn't move it to the Spec to me and I'm talking about the clock that I'm
holding in my hand.
So if the first event took place at x equals zero,
second one also takes place at x equals zero.
You understand I'm holding the clock.
I would travel forward in time.
It's Taos zero seconds later,
but the clock has not gone anywhere.
So the two events,
the two takings of the clock,
uh,
separated in space by zero and in time by [inaudible],
that means delta x is equal to zero.
Delta t is equal to zero.
What do you get according to you?
The time difference between the two ticks is Delta t,
which is zero minus you,
et Cetera.
At times zero divided by this factor.
That means the time difference between the two ticks would be bigger if that was
zero was one second.
If you divide one by one minus use squared overseas square,
you're going to find out it is less is more.
For example,
if this factor in the denominator,
this 0.5
then Delta t will be two times.zero.
In other words,
when your clock has taken one second to go from one topic to the next,
I will say according to me the real time elapses two seconds.
It can be 10 seconds.
That can be a hundred seconds.
You can make Delta t as big as you like letting you approach.
See,
yeah,
yes.
Thank you.
I'm having this problem today with the Prime v Prime is how zero over this.
If you put [inaudible] one second question there guys,
I wanted to
zero.
No,
you did not go to zero.
You is not zero.
You delta x overseas squared is the Dell tax that went to zero.
Go to the Lord and his transformation.
Uh,
Delta t prime is Delta t minus you delta x Overseas Square.
Delta x is zero because that's why.
That's where I'm telling the equation.
The clock is addressed with respect.
To me that means that too.
Rolling.
No,
no.
Let in this example,
let the unprimed observer be the one holding the clock.
Then Delta x is zero.
Delta t is whatever the time of the clock is one second.
Delta p prime is seen by anybody else going at a speed you relative to me.
You can also do it backwards by taking the clock in the hands of the s prime got
to do a little more work.
It's a lot easier to here because I get to pump into the equation to facts and
one shot that the time between the two takes is one second and it's addressed
with respect to me,
which is why the delta x vanished between the two ticks.
If I want to use your equations,
Delta x Prime won't be zero because a clock has moved and you got to do.
You can do it I think shown in my notes how to do that,
but it's unnecessary.
This is the main result.
Now here is a paradox.
You can go back to the backwards equations.
Uh,
let's do this informally.
Okay,
let's not write it again.
It will look like this,
right?
We know that.
Let's take a clock.
You are catty with ticks off one seconds.
So between the tick and the next tick the time differences,
one second,
space differences.
Zero.
I'd find Delta t is one over this way.
So I will say your clock is slow and you'll say my clock is slow.
How was that possible?
How can it be?
That'd be accused each other of having yes,
because the person who trained
the other observers,
well you're absolutely right.
The predictions are in agreement with that principle.
But I asked you to think about
the conflict you have.
Yes.
It's a visual perspective and that uh,
true people who are far away from each other,
you each other as people.
So that's very good when they are close up and that doesn't bring into it.
No,
that is correct.
He is.
Let me repeat what he said.
You said if there are two people,
David,
that right next to each other,
it'd be at the same height and they move apart and each person looks at the
other person and finds the person diminished in size because of the distance and
each person can tell the other person you look small from where I am.
In fact,
even more paradoxical is how in this world too,
people can simultaneously look down on each other.
You figured that out,
right?
There are two people who simultaneously have a higher opinion of themselves or
the other person and are the same thing.
They look down on each other.
I have not found it to how many space diminished.
I should embrace these people to make that possible.
But this is certainly correct that spatial resolution,
lets give the impression.
So here's the answer that is usually given to explain this to you.
If I take a real clock like this,
watch here and ask you why does it look slow?
Do you,
when I'm moving relative to you,
it's difficult because it's guardian or electronics and stuff and I still don't
know how to set the clock.
On My VCR,
I'm not going to figure that out.
So for all of us guys who are challenged,
that is a clock that's particularly simple and the clock works like this.
It has got two mirrors.
Okay.
And it light pulse,
yes,
goes up and down between the mirrors and every time it goes at a,
it's a round trip.
It sets off some detected and it goes click.
Now this is very important dimension that this is my x coordinate and that's the
white coordinate.
And I did not show you here that a logical arguments and why if you and I had
moving along x,
I would y coordinates if they agree in the beginning,
continue to agree.
That's because if you say something is two meters tall and they pass each other,
you cannot have a disagreement on the fact that heights of the same Radisson,
the linear dimension is room for discussion in the transfers dimension.
That is.
So anyway,
I have this block that goes up and down light bulb goes up and down it goes.
A certain distance.
L in the vertical direction and to l oversee is the time period of my clock.
That's the time for a round.
You look at my clock and what do you think is happening?
Remember?
Do you have moving to the right related to me.
So according to my clock is moving to the left and it looks like this.
Yeah,
light beam is going on a zigzag path according to you.
You agree?
That's very clear for me.
The balance is going up and down for you.
It's going on the high part in news.
You can,
you can imagine how with the high part and use use square and csquared are going
to come from drawing the sides of the triangle.
That's why the time will come out longer.
The way it be like this clock,
because we know everything about the operation of the clock.
We know that this path is longer than the straight up and down pat because the
transfers coordinators known to us,
but the more we know the velocity of late is the same in all frames of
reference.
So light going on a longer path is simply going to take longer.
So I know you're Clark would slow down.
Now here's the beauty.
The beauty is that if you have a clock that's going up and down,
straight up and down,
when I see it is going to look like this.
So it's as simple as saying that if you had these two clocks and I think is
going up and down,
you would think it's a zigzag this way and I look at your clock.
It is exactly the other way.
It's perfectly okay for me to say to you,
your light pulse is going on.
Hypebot yes,
mine is going up and down and why you can say that to me.
Hmm.
So at least this light plot explains to you why clocks will appear to be slow.
Now the question you can ask us,
what if I have some either pluck with the gears and wheels and teeth and
whatnot?
How does that slow down?
The onset is,
we don't know exactly how they explained that clock,
but I know that if you carry a light clock and another clock made up,
we,
you know,
we listened gears,
they should run at the same rate.
They should run at the same rate because if they ran a different rates,
one slow down in one,
didn't they?
Comparing the two clocks,
you can determine your velocity and that we know is impossible by the postulate
that you cannot detect uniform velocity that float.
If the light clock does something,
all clocks must do the same thing regardless of the mechanism
at that includes biological clocks.
So if you have a clock,
which is just yourself,
I look at you,
you know what,
a 15 or 20 years,
I notice some changes.
If they can tolerate,
then your hair turns white,
your teeth fall off.
That's a clock.
And that clock could also slow down because I don't care how your life systems
work,
but you are a clock and you got to slow down.
That's why you can make predictions about what will happen to living systems
even though that's not our business.
So in particularly if you take a clock,
which is made up of mechanical parts and human being and they're traveling at
high speeds,
the aging of the human being should slow down just like the clock sticking with
slaughter without knowing the reasons for it.
So this leads to a very famous paradox called the twin paradox.
The twin paradox say is that you got two guys,
twins.
Now this is this actually a valid example wanted at the same time,
same place,
and then one goes on a trip at some speed you and goes around and comes back.
So I think the person has been gone for 20 years.
My twin,
so let's say he was 20 when he left,
so I expected him to be 40 when he gets back.
But he'll come back younger because as a clock he has slowed down.
So what I think is 20 years,
this could be uh,
my time is 20 years,
but his time could be 10 because this factor downstairs is 0.5.
So you can come back to being younger than me.
Yes,
isn't it?
Isn't,
it isn't.
The paradox of rise in general is the time dilation is a bit not different
philosophy.
Uh,
but we got to be careful to his point hat is it something to do the
acceleration,
but the real question is this.
So if I am on the ground and I sent my twin on the trip and we meet
now the clocks are being compared as long as the zigzag is going this way and
that Zack is going that way.
You can say what you like,
but what are the clocks I brought head to head done compared can they both be
slower than the other?
We know that's impossible.
So instead of clocks,
we use human beings and dramatize a paradox and see who will be younger.
Me Are the twin who went on the rocket.
Well that can only one answer that question and yet the water,
the twin says,
well I have no reason to believe that I moved.
You're the one who went on the trip the opposite way,
so you've got to be younger than me.
Yes.
I guess the kids at the twin,
those that because he felt wildly effective,
the acceleration that necessarily had to bring him back to the circle,
you can just travel on going straight line and uh,
not accelerate and then meet the twin backward.
Very good.
Okay.
I couldn't have said it better.
Let me repeat it.
The point is,
as long as you've got oppositely moving clocks,
they can believe what they want of each other.
But if you want the clock to be subject to a comparison,
then it can never,
you can never compare objects that are constantly moving at opposite velocities.
So somebody has got to turn it on and come back.
So in the case of the twin,
he and I about addressed the twin guard into the rocket,
the setup,
the velocity difference between him and me.
So in the early stages,
he is the 100 going acceleration and not me.
Likewise,
the twin went somewhere and stopped and turned around and came back the twin to
suffering the deceleration.
So that our two periods,
at least during the voyage when the twin has no right to claim that he is not
moving that I act.
That's why,
but you don't have the same status vet as for me the whole time Newton's laws
and the loss of in that she ever operative for me.
Let us put him on the rocket duding tick off.
Things started flying off and doing landing.
Things started flying off.
He cannot possibly claim he has the same status as me.
That's the way that problem,
that relationship is not symmetrical and one person can say I did not move
because I was always initial other it will say have to concede that he moved.
Yes
first
and then the other one.
Yeah.
Then if you do it,
if you give them symmetrical accelerations,
what leave like this and both come back.
Then both we'd like to be on the age but they will disagree with the person on
the ground support.
That's the triplets.
You got tripped lesson to.
Kids are sent out that way.
Third one stays back.
The third one that stays back will be older than the others.
So this is not science fiction at all.
If you want to be alive for the year 3000 you can do it.
Just have to get into a rocket at sufficient velocity,
close to the speed of light so that this is 3000 years.
Okay.
And you figured out how long you got to live,
maybe another 50 years.
Do the math,
you find the speed getting the rocket and go and come back.
Now this experiment's done all the time with microscopic particles.
You know they are accelerated in Fermi lab for example,
they go around on the ring and just by virtue of their motion,
they live a very long time.
So particles that are supposed to have a short lifetime,
which you calculate in their own rest frame live much longer because they are
moving.
And one way to keep them moving is to put them on an accelerated ring and they
live for a very long time.
Yes,
well the guy on the rocket,
the rocket itself,
no,
no rocket guy will think rocket will think I am 50 years older.
If you went on the rocket,
it's 50 years for you.
For people on the grounders 3000 years.
You're still figures on the rocket.
Yeah,
but if you don't want to age at all,
you cannot change it.
You want what,
five years?
Okay.
We just fixed the number.
You want the age only 0.5 years.
That's another number you'll never run out of numbers.
You can let you approach seat as much as you like and you can live as long as
you want and come back whenever you want.
Other issues like going backwards in time,
I'll come back to that later that are problems with that.
We'll come to that,
but you can stop time as far as we know and we see it all the time and wants to
produce in the upper atmosphere.
Uh,
their lifetime is something 10 to the minus six seconds or whatever.
Even if the travel,
the speed of light,
c times that time is not long enough to cross the atmosphere,
but they make it here.
How did they make it?
They make it because their lifetime is computed in their frame of reference.
They still think delivered only their lifetime,
but I think they lived a much longer.
That's how they made it to the earth,
but how about from that point of view?
They only lived a short time and how did they go to a hundred kilometers?
That's the next thing I'm going to tell you.
According to them,
the atmosphere is not a hundred kilometers but maybe eight kilometers long and
that's the last point which has to do with the length contraction.
So length contraction says,
oh by the way,
it's the thing to remember about time.
Dilatation is every clock runs the fastest in his own restaurant.
In any other frame of reference in which the clock has any velocity,
it will appear to be slower than the advertised time period of the client.
Good.
Last thing I want to do is linked contraction.
Yeah.
Length contraction says if you have a meter stick and you and I bought them from
the same store,
once you're in this plane on this rocket,
I will claim your meter sticks that actually shorter than a meter.
In fact,
the shortening factor is this.
This is a driving factor.
In fact,
we are back in the derivation of the load and Samsung summation,
the fudge factory calculated.
Taking your links into my links is precisely connected with this factor.
If you say the leg,
the something,
I will tell you that the length is actually less than that
because your meter sticks or short.
But let me prove that to you.
So let's take a rod that's moving
is moving at a speed.
You,
you're carrying the rock and I want to find this length.
What should I do?
That's the question.
Okay,
so rod is moving at speed.
You and I want to find this link.
So
delta x prime is delta x minus you Delta t over the square root.
I'm gonna make a pan of events to find the length of the rod event.
One.
Remember this rod is zooming past me even at one is when this president of the
rod hits a certain marking on the meter,
on my graduated x axis,
and even to this from the back end of the train hits my audition.
And the distance between those two is the length of the rod provided one
condition.
How do you find the length of a moving rod?
You find this end and that end at the same time.
Otherwise you will screw up,
right?
If you find this and now go on lunch break and come back with the artists over
there and say that's the rear end of the rod and you get that to be the leg
that's not up.
You find the length of a moving optic.
You find the length by measuring the coordinates of the two ends at the same
time.
Consequently at the same time means Delta t must be zero.
Delta l is the delta.
X is the length according to you
according to the person going with the rod and the two events since they take
place at the two ends of the rod are separated by the length of the rod because
there are,
according to you is not going anywhere.
I suppose you have a Rod.
It's not moving it a little to you.
Something happens at one and something happens at the other end.
What's the spacial distance between them?
It's the length of the rock.
That's the meaning of the length of the Rod.
Therefore,
if you cross multiply,
you get this result,
Ellis l zero times.
So the real length.
So rod will appear longest in his restaurant and to anybody else who lapierre
shorter
blocks up we had fastest and the best frame rods up here longest and the right,
but anybody to whom rod is moving that art appears shorts.
So here's another paradox then.
Uh,
I make a hole in my x axis.
I make the whole to be half a meter long.
This is half a meter.
You and I bought a meter stick.
They are moving at a velocity where this number has become half
you oversee is one over route two,
two squared overseas squares that what?
Look,
it's whatever it takes to make this factor half.
So I expect you admitted stick to have front to half this length.
So I make a hole on the table,
half a meter long.
The rod goes by.
I think it will fall into the hole.
That's my expectation.
You come and say my meters big is a meter stick.
The whole that you've done that you think has happened meters long,
actually quarter meter law.
So there is no way this my meter stick is going through that hole in the table
because it's four times as long as a hole in the table.
You understand that normally you make a meter stick,
you put it on top of the hole at the same length,
it'll fall down.
But if it's a moving meter stick,
which is contracted according to me from one meter to half a meter,
half a meter hole is enough but it to fall.
But from your vantage point,
my half a meter hole looks like a quarter of a meter hole you're made to stick,
still look like a meter.
The question is when this experiment occurs,
will it fall or not?
Okay.
In diesel,
all paradoxes,
if you invented the theory,
you gotta defend these paradoxes.
You cannot get to answers to one question.
That's the logical issue.
So the answer to these problems is if you know one point of view in Whitford is
correct,
that's the right answer.
Then the other person has to figure out what happened.
So from my point of view,
if I made a half a meter hole and your rod is struggling to have the length it's
going to fall so it will fall.
The question is how does the other person reconcile himself to the fact that he
had an aquatic.
That person,
the whole is a quarter meter long in the rod is one meter long.
Well I should put it the fall.
You've got to give it a little tilt.
Okay,
so that it can actually fall in.
I give it a little tilt here.
How can this object fall into that and
yeah.
The way other person explains it is you said first this and went in here.
Other than we're sticking way out.
Then sometime later the second end went in here and that's how I got to the
hole.
Namely the two ends did not go at the same time
that way it's certainly possible for a two meters.
One meter stick to go through a quarter percent.
The middle hole in the table,
I mean give the rod or a little tilt so it can fall into the hall.
The tip enters first.
The tail is way outside.
Then after awhile the tale goes in.
In that manner,
the rod goes in so they can reconcile this how to docs by saying,
uh,
the two ends did not go at the same time.
Also,
if you ask the other person who thinks something is two meters long and the
other person think it is half a meter long,
how did they reconcile it?
I say I measured the to enter the same time,
but you will tell me you did not measure the ends of my meters thick.
At the same time you measured one end and you goofed off.
Then he came back and measured the second end.
By the time the rod had slipped to the right,
you mentioned that then and you goofed off.
You wait until it came there.
Then you mentioned the other day,
that's why you got half instead of one
and nobody's right or wrong.
I did measure the tumor and simultaneously according to me,
but you don't have to agree they were simultaneous.
So it's by it.
By going soft on what simultaneity means that you're able to reconcile this with
the Newtonian day simultaneity is absolute linked with absolute in relativity.
Simultaneity is relative and length is also related because the operational way
to find the length of a body will not satisfy all observers.
If I find the length of your moving meter stick,
the two ends at the same time,
you will say,
I didn't measure them at the same time.
And the formula is relatively,
I love that.
That's,
so we live with the fact that we accused to that of having relatively short
meter sticks.
I blame you on your measurement,
but that blame is not as genuine blame because you can dig a hole equals the
reduced length and things a little fall in.
So you have every right to say things have shrunk and I will say I didn't
shrink.
I fell in because my notes went in first and then a little later.
The tailwind that are various paradoxes.
I'll just leave you with one.
You have a garage,
your parents build your garage 12 meters long.
You bought a car 14 minutes long.
Can you park it right?
If you've got a sufficiently high velocities.
So the 14 gets shunted,
12 there'll be a brief instant in which both ends of your car are inside the
garage.
Okay?
Of course you will have to smash through the back end of the garage,
but you will maintain,
yes,
I smashed in that,
but my car was in the garage for some time and the parent will say,
no,
the front end went smashed.
The rear,
the back hadn't even come in.
Little later the back came.
So everyone will agree.
You broke the garage.
He brought the car and the lengths were contracted relative to each other.
And the phenomenon is that according to you,
that was a time the whole car is in the garage.
And according to the parents,
it was not.